[Music]
this is like the first time I hearts are
venema calories so this is a pretty cool
experience coming in so it's a freshman
like I didn't imagine my heart would be
in the Student Center that Europe that
was really cool and it was also just
like really nice to see like a lot of
different artists like for me like like
there's like grad students in this
program this undergrad students like
this whole wide range of different
people with different experiences and it
just all comes together in one gallery
the opportunity to experience new
formulas of expression is a really
valuable experience for undergraduates
and graduates and I'm really glad that
the arts college gives us that
opportunity
[Music]
what's most rewarding for me is seeing
the new Weiser gallery because I have
had art displayed here in the old one
and the new one is just so much better
it feels like an art gallery now and
that's really exciting so this is I
think much nicer to have here because it
does feel more like a space that it's
for art